all right word of advice in the future
to not whistle for notes while showing
the number three on your fingers because
you're gonna your ass beat probably shot
[Music]
The Hunger Games Catching Fire
so Catching Fire is part two of The
Hunger Games trilogy which actually the
movies aren't going to be a trilogy
because they're splitting Mockingjay
into two parts because got to do that
nowadays splitting the last movie into
two parts just what needs to happen now
and I mean where we left off in the
Hunger Games is Katniss and Peeta told
the evil not so Galactic Empire yeah now
Emperor guessed all from Final Fantasy 6
is really pissed off and he's like
Katniss is such a pain in my sack you
know what she needs to diagnose killer
and Philip Seymour Hoffman he's like
let's turn her into one of us in the
eyes of the people then we'll kill her
and now Katniss needs to enter the
Hunger Games again this time with
winners of previous year's of the Hunger
Games that's right this time around it's
like MTV's Road rules all-stars you know
what I'm talking about
oh I you marathon that [ __ ] engine hey
we all have because Katniss has become a
symbol of hope and evil empires they
don't like hope needs to be stomped out
and I was really digging this movie
about an hour into it though I was like
they still haven't entered the Hunger
Games I'm a little concerned but
ultimately at this point it's not about
the tournament it's not about The Hunger
Games it's about the bigger picture kind
of [ __ ] the Hunger Games event itself is
a tool to tell a story the story
ultimately is revolution and I like how
everyone in The Hunger Games this time
around has been a winner so they
ultimately alliances start farming
because alliances form and reality
television we've all seen it a hundred
times over and when I first saw pictures
of this character Finnick I was like
okay he's gonna be the new generic
douchebag I get it then when Finnick
first comes on the scene I was like I
like that dude I don't know if he's a
dick I don't know if he's nice but if
he's a dick he's not cooled air and as
forming uneasy alliances this time
around wood habit Katniss teams up with
Phoenix what smarmy Aquaman Katniss
Peeta and the old dude from thinner and
now we have a movie I can tell you till
I'm blue in the face that Catching Fire
is in fact better than the first Hunger
Games movie but you need to know one
thing folks no more shaky cam that's
right action scenes this time around
don't look like Oh run go go go my god
there's so much blood
I enjoyed the first movie I'm just
saying that shakey cam really but I was
in fact really amazed that half the
movie takes place in the actual Hunger
Games and that didn't bother me at all
I like bigger picture kind of [ __ ] you
by the fact that this Katniss girl did
one act of defiance and that's just all
it takes for dominoes to go you saw V
for Vendetta right when you lines up the
dominoes and he's all just like wow it's
all slow motion everything gets thrown
at her in this movie which makes it a
lot more relevant in the first movie
yeah the dogs were coming after her and
fireballs were getting lobbed at her you
kind of saw the game makers were kind of
hurting the game to go in certain
direction it's just the name of the game
really this time around you feel like
it's like nah she just needs to die it
is Katniss versus the world the movie
has some conveniences in it for sure you
walk out of the movie start driving home
you're like wait a minute if that is a
well but the Dark Knight Rises had like
452 conveniences and that movie was cool
it is my opinion that movie was cool in
the end the Hunger Games Catching Fire
was exciting it was great it delves
deeper into the world of The Hunger
Games the Empire defines holding your
ground against all odds and most of all
friends hope it's certainly a step up
from the first movie I will say The
Hunger Games Catching Fire is worth
buying on blu-ray so The Hunger Games
Catching Fire did you see it what did
you think about it did you like it
better than the Hunger Games vice-versa
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you